I know you have a four-year degree but
you also have filmmaking degree is that
or certificate certificate is
essentially like a trade school great as
a trade school I went to in East LA and
I was there for about a year
it has different each semester is like a
different level of difficulty or like
more requirements someone for about a
year graduated with two certificates
from there and um yeah that's where I
learned I mean a lot of the different
stuff I'm kind of like how to you know
any direct a film or be an ad on a film
just a director all different jobs
basically how to edit and all that stuff
and then I kind of took from there and
decided I really wanted to do which was
writing and directing my own material so
it sounds like you had a positive
experience there but that being said do
you think someone still needs film
school to make movies no they don't I
well it depends on the individual
because you need to either way you need
to the best way to learn I was in
hands-on just pick up camera start
shooting stuff I mean there's been a lot
of big-name directors that have start
out ed even once I love I think we're
dreaming to go to film school they just
started picked up a camera and started
shooting and kind of taught themselves
what you can your best film school
really is watching films because then
you learn how to up with you can see the
different shots they use for the film
and kind of take from that okay there's
different shots and stuff so watching a
lot of films and then you know just pick
a camera pick up a camera and just start
shooting stuff but some people are you
know may be better for the film school
may that they learn better me
essentially I wanted to go just because
I I didn't really just want to walk in
blind and start picking up with Cameron
she I kind of wanted some type of
instruction just to get started so it
kind of helped would learning the basics
and then from narrows is relatively
simple when she wanted basically you
just kind of build off of there you can
see their films watching their movies
and how I put stuff together what did
you learn about working with other
people whether it was just where you
know you guys were all on the editing
Bay's together on Adobe Premiere Pro or
what you know I think that's what we
usually you know collaborating or just
even just
on a break talking about ideas what was
it about the working with other people
that you picked up the most from about
filmmaking um what you see everyone
else's process and how they put together
a film and their style what works and
what doesn't so you can kind of talk to
them based on okay they'll give you
advice okay you know this this works for
for this if you're gonna do this certain
way like shoot a film this way you get a
lot of advice on different ways to not
skyrocket your budget I would say my
talking to our people obviously you
learn from their filmmakers and
directors producers like hey this is a
way you can save money you're not
spending thousands thousands dollars
like some people who I've seen some
people come into the business and
they've never made a film not even a
short film I feature or anything and
they're like hey I have all this money I
had his money I wanna make a feature
film or whatever I want to produce it
right I just don't know what I'm doing
so those people come in they start
talking about people and hiring people
in the business but they don't really
know well and then they start giving
these huge budget breakdowns like oh you
need all this money for this huge crew
or all these grips and gaffers and stuff
for this film you need all these people
need all his money and they end up
making this film for all his money when
really they could have made it for one
fourth or they can really need all those
people which I you had for me I've had
like a before I made my feature I was
thing about working on our production
company and they had like this big
breakdown of this huge crew and I told
my my team of feels like do we don't
need all those people I've done this all
my short films with a very relatively
smaller crew it's a lot cheaper you know
it's a lot better with this I think you
don't need all this stuff and I talked
to my scimitar for who's produce and
stuff and he's like yeah we'll do this
it's this and worked out fine so I think
talking to hired filmmakers with are in
the business you can learn from them on
you know things will work for making
your budget relative small
you